jesse social media has become so much
more of a force i think than anyone
anticipated back when myspace and
facebook came onto the scene
less than 20 years ago now given what we
know about it
do you think that social media is more
of a force for good or a force for evil
i think it's still a force for good if
we actively allow it to be right now we
see a very caustic audience with a
certain age demographic that didn't grow
up with these tools being in their
pocket every day so they're very
comfortable being on a platform like
facebook and just writing garbage in the
comment section but if we consider the
incoming group of educators who are
finishing university who are going into
teaching environments where they
themselves grew up with social media as
a concern for safety or a concern for
how they conduct themselves they're
better prepared to work with kids who
have grown up with these tools as an
everyday because they've had ipads and
phones aimed at them since since
basically the day they were born because
that's the society that we've created so
there's a whole generation growing up as
you said that have like my son who is 17
who know nothing but the digital age it
this is their era social media is almost
like a second language are you
suggesting that they're not vulnerable
then because they're growing up in this
and they're so much more self-aware the
vulnerability has to run on a spectrum
and so the idea of vulnerability when we
talk to kids about internet safety has
always been about protect yourself from
predation currently in canada we see a
large amount of seniors people who are
in let's say the 55-plus demographic of
financial viability being targeted who
are falling prey to scams online where
it's you know buy gift cards online or
somebody who's targeted you for a cra
scam and we have a lot of young people
who don't fall for that kind of cat
fishing mentality because they've
understood what it means to fall for
something in a gaming environment so
their digital literacies their media
literacies are more adept to kind of
sussing out the garbage and the same
applies to their idea of collecting
information and kind of going through
misinformation well let's talk about big
tech companies i mean you know that what
underpins them is enormous wealth and
profit built on
a lot of the darkness that has happened
online right they have used our data to
profit hugely
where does that leave you in terms of
optimism for how
things are going to work in the next
couple of decades so majority of social
media users have this kind of
proprietary idea that what they do on
the platform is theirs right and so we
see people post things on social media
pages where it says facebook does not
have the right to use my information but
you didn't read the 17 pages of terms of
service to actually use that website you
didn't understand what you gave up the
exchange of information is the currency
i want to ask you beyond individuals
which is important but to state actors
when you have countries such as russia
using very sophisticated technologies
even artificial intelligence to spread
misinformation to spread propaganda and
it really does undermine democracy it
very much does and the idea that
democracy now is twofold the idea that
individuals will see something on the
internet and believe it to be true and
that's how they go to the voting booth
that that's a big concern because if
people are voting based on this
information that democratic process is
severely in jeopardy well and we know
that it has happened it will continue to
happen it's not stopping it's ramping up
i do want those individuals to get good
information that isn't based on a person
who's sitting in a basement in moscow
trying to get somebody to decide who our
elected leader should be in canada so
within that space yes there is going to
be a weaponization for your vote but
it's also weaponization for the way that
you see the world and in that it's very
easy to get individuals to believe
propaganda and we've known that well
before the internet existed i mean it's
just part of media but the hard part
here for the majority of people who are
subscribing to this information is that
it is affirming pieces of the way that
they want to see the world and in that
that echo chamber then becomes something
that social media amplifies they find
like-minded individuals and then those
people come out of the woodwork and kind
of come together in a group one person's
belief of what's valuable news might be
entirely different than others and now
the internet just exacerbates that well
the internet exacerbates it and certain
political actors also exacerbate it
right to their own advantage and and the
idea that
this is whole the russian propaganda
model right is that you uh you disrupt
and you make people uncertain about what
the truth really is but the idea that
you could weaponize that and you can get
people to chant it at a crowd or that's
propaganda in itself we're seeing that
in canada with aspects of politicians
who are standing in the house and
calling the prime minister a tyrant
right there's no evidence to that so
according to the oxford dictionary a
dictator is a ruler with total power
over a country typically one who has
obtained control by force
there are many canadians that would
believe
that would hold the view
that this does apply to mr trudeau the
prime minister of canada but it's a good
sound bite and it gets people who have
put that individual into space um a
little bit more emboldened in the
ability that they can sit in a room and
chant something as well correct me if
i'm wrong but i don't think we have any
real uh way to in a sophisticated way
fight back against the stuff that russia
is doing no we don't we don't and i i
think that can evolve over time when it
comes to you can't fool me if i if i'm
aware and so luckily our school
districts have you know independent
curriculum but our provinces really are
kicking out more and more digital
citizenship curriculum to get this at an
earlier age where they ask questions to
young people about what they see online
how they perceive those themes but if we
have individuals who are emerging into
that voting space who are between the
ages of 18 and 35 and say no i'm going
to do a little bit of homework here
before i step in i'm going to understand
that the the themes that are in my
community and then go further and see
what's affecting my country and ask
myself when i see something
is it factual is there is there
information beyond what this one video
snippet if we get people more and more
doing that we are going to be on a more
optimistic side of the coin and
hopefully we become more media literate
because of that